in european folklore arcs of mushrooms
known as fairy rings were considered a
portal into a different world
these mesmerizing patterns are also seen
in the grasslands of namibia
where meters wide barren circles speckle
the landscape
to ecologists these shapes are
enchanting but
not for their magical properties they
give important clues about the health of
an ecosystem
and how they might respond to change
most research on these self-organizing
patterns are in systems where fairy
circles persist long term
but in salt marshes these shapes are
part of early development
a stepping stone to establishing
widespread expanses of vegetation
now researchers have gained more insight
into these fleeting patterns
researchers used experimental testing
and mathematical modeling
to uncover how fairy circles form in
salt marshes
first they picked a young marsh to
observe they settled on the mud flats of
chongming island
and the nonhue title flats near shanghai
while marshes in many places have been
shrinking due to sea level rise
some marshes in china have expanded by
hundreds of meters a year
human development and the expansion of
farmlands pushing more sediment into the
yancey river
has expanded shorelines
during an aerial survey of the area
scientists observed rings that nestled
inside each other
and that these rings often merged in
arid environments rings repel each other
they used mathematical models to
recreate these patterns
and found two mechanisms driving them
one
the accumulation of the toxic chemical
sulfide
created when bacteria decomposes dead
plant matter
the other nutrient depletion in the
center of the rings
from heightened competition with other
plants less competition with plants
expanding outwardly
means more available nutrients to test
if these ecological processes or driving
patterns
scientists sampled from different areas
of fairy circles
the center of rings on the rings and the
bare outer edge
they found higher concentrations of
sulfide in the center samples
than on the rings and margins
although the measured amounts were not
high enough to kill plants
researchers say sampling during hotter
times of day
could yield lethal levels they did find
conclusive evidence that a lack of
nutrients played a major role in the
formation of these rings
in experiments on the salt marsh adding
nitrogen fertilizer to the center patch
increased their growth while adding it
on the rings hardly gave a boost
researchers say this study provides a
good starting point for figuring out
what could limit the expansion of
marshes in other areas
since marshes serve important functions
from buffering against storm surges
to capturing carbon understanding the
mechanisms that underlie their success
is crucial
taking a bird's-eye view of other
marshes could reveal the secrets to
their success
you